sonic screwdrivers wacky outfits and
young female companions have all become
staples of the doctor who TV series
after two seasons with Jenna Coleman
travelling through time and space it
looks like the doctor has a new friend
I'm Simon and this is your entertainment
news update ever since Jenna Coleman
announced her departure from the
long-running sci-fi show Doctor Who last
year fans had been speculating about who
will take over as the Time Lords
companion it has been revealed that pole
Mackey will play the doctors next
assistant the actress made her doctor
who debut alongside Peter Capaldi this
weekend in a new trailer as the clip
suggests Mackey won't be seen in her
role as bill until 2017 when the next
season premieres this will be the 10th
season since the show rebooted in 2005
and the last under the guidance of
showrunner Steven Moffat Capaldi who has
played the doctor since 2013 described
macchiata fine actress with a wonderful
zest and shot he added she's a
refreshing addition to the TARDIS and
will bring a universe of exciting new
possibilities to the doctors adventures
Moffat's departure follows six years in
charge of the show is to be replaced
from season 11 by Chris Chibnall who has
worked on such prominent British shows
as broadchurch life on Mars law and
order UK and the Doctor Who spin-off
Torchwood do you think bill will live up
to her predecessors who's your favorite
companion let me know in the comments or
come find me on Twitter I'm at the
journal thanks for watching and for all
your entertainment news keep it gamespot